welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the lord
of the rings the rings of power episodes
one and two gonna merge a virtual
weapons together for you this series
adapts an area of jrr tolkien's middle
earth about which we know very little
other than the ending but still in these
first two episodes impressively manages
to weave in mystery and some stunning
production design so let's break down
the deeper meaning and details that you
might have missed in these first two
episodes and just to be clear i don't
give a [ __ ] about any of the reasons
people are mad at the show to me this is
all fantasy and i'm just loving the ride
and my job with this breakdown is just
to point out all the cool stuff about it
that i like so episode one opens with
the voice of galadriel nothing is evil
in the beginning
and there was a time when the world was
so young there had not yet been a
sunrise
but even then
there was light gladreal is our
protagonist of the series an elven
warrior played by morphin clark the
elder version of whom is played by kate
blanchett in the peter jackson films the
events of lord of the rings take place
in the third age of middle-earth this
series will be set during the
little-known second age the end of that
age was recapped by galadriel's
voiceover in the prologue to peter
jackson's fellowship of the ring when
sauron tricked the elves and dwarves and
men into forging the 19 rings of power
while he secretly had the one ring to
rule them all this series will document
how those characters got to that point
but in this opening before galadriel
even speaks we hear some singing voices
[Music]
this is the song of the valinor
described later by elrond i hear it said
that
when you cross over you hear a song
one whose memory we all carry
and you are immersed in a light more
intoxicating than any sensation in all
of middle earth for adult galadriel this
is a haunting siren song a warning that
she cannot go home again truly none of
us can and with the words nothing is
evil in the beginning this series taps
into a core distinction with tolkien's
themes evil is not a constant absolute
that always existed in the world it's
something that is forged by decisions
and concessions at the end of the day
goodness still runs through all things
and while that goodness can be corrupted
it still remains there and it is the one
constant that was always there before
the sunrise it can always be found again
as our dear friend sam wise will tell us
ages from now there is goodness left in
the world mr frodo and it's worth
fighting for this pre-sunrise light that
we're in right now actually comes from
the two trees of eleanor lorelei and tel
perrion this land of alan or is the
ethereal undyne realm located across the
sea from middle earth this is created by
the valar kind of the archangels of this
universe high elves were actually
originally awakened in middle earth but
then were brought to valinor though not
the sylvan elves who stayed behind a
middle earth young galadriel folds
parchment that unfolds into an elven
swan boat foreshadowing her own voyage
at the end of this episode including how
she doesn't complete that voyage this
boat transforms midstream just as
galadriel will finally understand her
brother's wisdom as she is mid-voyage
her brother finrod lifts the boat with
his dagger the dagger that will later
become hers as she takes on his mission
to hunt sauron he turns the boat into a
parable here stone sink because they can
only look downward whereas boats fix
their gaze forward toward the light he
whispers a secret about how the boat
would know where to go revealed at the
end of the episode sometimes we cannot
know
until we have touched the darkness
another important theme to this series
we know that the distant future of this
narrative will end with frodo leaving
with the elves including galadriel on a
vessel to valinor but before any of us
can earn that final passage we must
touch the darkness at least galadriel
explains how the two trees get
extinguished by the forces of morgoth
plunging valinor into darkness so here
we are seeing the first age events
documented in the silmarillion these are
the wars of the jewels aka the simarils
these are the precious gems that were
actually crafted from the light to the
two trees these trees were destroyed
actually in the book by melkor in the
spider the unguliant here we see the
trees turning black as if poisoned which
may actually be the same black bile that
spews from the cow and inks through the
leaf that king gilgalad catches and as
the elves leave their home of eleanor to
return to middle earth right away we see
this insane battle including some eagles
fighting some felbis looking flying
creatures so for any of you smart asses
out there who think they were the first
one to discover that tolkien plato why
didn't they just take the eagles to
mordor this is why my friends sauron had
freaking nazz gold riding on some
felbies the eagles weren't the only
things that could fly back then the
skies were not safe and the eagles you
couldn't blame them for not being the
ego to die like this so when your enemy
has aerial firepower it means you gotta
walk the long way with a couple hobbits
and a golem i love how finron skewers
two orcs in one stab and he screams
valeron kaladen
which translates to by the light of the
valar and therovante
they will die these are both in the
elvish language of quenia we see some
bodies on spears float in the water this
is the aftermath of the war of wrath the
final of these wars which defeated
morgoth but sunk the landmass of
valerian so avenging her brother
galadriel hunts sauron for centuries up
until where we now catch up with her in
the forward waif using finrod's dagger
to stab the ice wall interesting before
he used it to fish her paper boat from
the stream now she uses it to plunge
deeper into a frozen stream thunder asks
how long can living flash endure where
even sunlight fears to tread galadriel
responds we are losing the light now
they are talking about the literal
daylight but metaphorically galatreal
sees this as an existential battle
between light and dark she seems far
more alive in the darkness of this
opening sequence than she ever is in the
light of the ending of the episode they
find morgoth's old strongholds in this
hidden room
these orcs were meddling with the powers
of the unseen world
some dark sorcery of old
but what was their purpose presumably
these orcs aided sauron in a ritual to
exile him maybe to the void or to help
shape-shift him into whatever new form
he has now taken in this series
galadriel's even wrong in thinking that
he went further north no no no she's
pointed the wrong direction he's more
likely in the south lands right under
their noses his symbol still burns hot
sizzling the snow as it lands similar to
how on the ring of power it was revealed
in heat despite that ring itself staying
quite cool we glide into the map showing
the rovanian wilderlands the contour of
the map dissolves perfectly into the
live-action hillside that's so widely
satisfying two hunters wearing moose
antlers past a group of camouflaged
harfoots these are the ancestral
predecessors to hobbits described in
tolkien's prologue to fellowship of the
ring concerning hobbits they're led by
sadok the elder and trail finder he
tracks the stars in his book to guide
the group on their migration path our
vocal character is nori brandyfoot the
brandyfoot family name most likely a mix
of hobbit families like the proud foots
the likely descendants of the brandy
foots the story goes that tolkien
started really with the sentence in a
hole in the ground there lived a hobbit
and built his entire middle earth
fiction from there and truly here i love
how we just see these heart foots
emerging from holes the berry patch that
nori and poppy lead the kids into is
patrolled by this wolf creature likely
the same one that cleared the field
leaving those two hunters empty-handed
then on to elrond he paula newman
here
yes elrond is half alvin the future
leader of the elves played by hugo
weaving in the peter jackson films but
here played by robert aramaio who played
young ned stark in game of thrones the
quinya he reads and writes translates to
the far west the undying lands tis an
end denied yes as the king's heralds he
is writing the speech that gil gallod
will later recite as galadriel and
elrond speak to each other notice how
the camera stays tight on their faces
this is a recurring visual of the
director j.e biona uses just an
interesting contrast with all the
sweeping landscapes we see in the series
including this overhead shot showing
them with the crashing waves beneath as
if the sea is beckoning galadriel to
leave the matters of middle earth behind
but even though she doesn't go to
valinor her destiny remains on the seas
because that is where she meets hal
brand marigold tells nori we are about
ripples in a long long stream
our path set by the pass and seasons
interesting how high elves like elijah
see themselves as a boat on a stream
whereas the harpoons see themselves as
the ripples of that stream yet how that
is so freeing for them a freedom that
galadriel by leaving the boat and
becoming the ripple will give herself as
gil glide honors galadriel and her
consort with the ceremony right before
he crowns her there is a look of
defiance in her eyes because she knows
that sending her to valinor isn't really
an honor for her it's more of an exile
as we all learn later gilgalad even
admits that the shadow of the past does
still exist he does this because he
worries galadriel's hunt is just gonna
further incite its rise galadriel visits
this grove honoring all these fallen
elephant warriors all these are famous
figures the first we see is her brother
finrod but we also see this female
carving this is likely luthien elron's
ancestor who fell in love with the human
baron the female elf famous for beating
morgoth at one point beside her is her
hound huan elrond warns that if
gallagher hell refuses the cult of
eleanor he will linger here
an outcast
poisoned in dark whispers and dreams but
galadriel rightly says that this kind of
eternal paradise would just drive her
mad
you say i have one victory over all the
horrors of middle earth
yet you would leave them alive in me
yes leaving the horrors of battle alive
and eternal war heroes yeah galatra
would rather live on as the bark of a
tree than actually live forever forever
with regret on to the south lands where
we made arundeal a sylvan elf serving as
a soldier patrolling these areas after
all many of these south landers years
ago did stand with morgoth their side
lost and many of them still haven't
gotten over it including the drunken
rowan in the bar here who says that
their true king will return and the
south will rise again but this actually
poses an interesting theory who is this
king who will return i'll talk about
that a bit later it is worth noting
though that the section of the map that
shows the southlands with that range of
mountains to the west actually matches
the map region where mordor is located
later on in history it's possible that
we are now seeing the origins of mordor
on this series maybe those orcs digging
under everything are currently
terraforming this land preparing outside
bronwyn gives aaron deal some alfair in
seeds alferin is a flower that he hasn't
seen since he was a child because aaron
deal grew up in the valerian that was
the landmass that sank in the war of
wrath so these flowers were native that
area and would be very very hard to find
his partner medwar says only twice in
known history has a pairing between
elves and humans even been attempted so
one of these periods was luthien and
baron elron's ancestors that's not the
only side of the family where he's had
these parents because another pairing
was tour in israel their son was erendil
the mariner who birthed elrond and his
brother l rose whom we're gonna meet in
episode three most likely irandale and
bronwyn realized this poison cow was
raising east and hordern and they head
off and theo sneaks in his french
southwestern to check out this ancient
broken sword that's marked with sauron
sigil and he gets a vision of flames
just as touching the ring of power would
flash one the eye of sauron so one big
mystery of the series is since it
promises to show the return of sauron
which of these characters might be
sauron in disguise could it be the
mystery stranger who arrives or the
meteorite could it be galadriel
southlander exile in episode 2 hal brand
i don't know i don't know if we've met
the character who's going to be revealed
as sauron yet we might not even meet him
in the first season of this show in fact
it could be that sauron just lives on in
this broken sword looking for a host to
corrupt and possess in episode 2 we do
see theo giving some of his blood to
help this sword reforge and grow could
it be theo who becomes sauron toast or
maybe theo could become one of the
nazgul like a king from the southlands
who becomes one of the nine men who
carries the nine rings of power in terms
of what sword this is i wonder if it's
the angrist the sword of bjorn that cut
a silmaril jewel from the iron crown of
morgoth and then shortly after shattered
one of its shards supposedly remained
lodged in morgoth's body bronwyn leaves
iran deal over the hill this shot
paralleling finrod's arrival to the
glorious valinor in the opening scene
but this time the town is in flaming
ruins galadriel and the rest approach
the valinor birds greet them the
warriors drawing the song of the
balinore it all feels very culty but
still beautiful the passage into the
valinor takes the form of a blinding
rainy mist which perfectly adapts
tolkien's description of the gray rain
curtain in the far green country burst
from fellowship of the ring and frodo's
dream in the house of tom bombadil a
memory that was called back at the very
end of return of the king peter jackson
actually reassigned this description to
gandalf when he was talking to pippin
who returned to the king grey
and all turns to silver glass
and then you see it
white shores
and beyond
a far green country
into a swift sunrise
but as galatreal remembers finrad's
wisdom about a sinking stone in this
moment we cut to a meteor crashing from
the sky one thing finally linking all of
these characters together including a
family of ants a parent clutching that's
young this meteor is the metaphorical
stone that contrasts galadriel's boat
from the opening parallel it represents
the darkness and the mystery that she
must first touch before she can pass on
actually love that the moment this stone
crashes the sound effect sinks but the
moment galadriel crashes into the water
like a stone
and maybe it's just a coincidence but as
the valinor gate closes the slit it
forms does resemble the eye of sauron
sauron being the returning evil that
awaits her back in middle earth visually
it also links her with another eye shape
the crater of the stranger which brings
us on to episode two now we get an
awesome opening credit sequence the
imagery forming grains of sand and rock
converging first into nine rings
representing the nine rings forged for
the men three reports for the elves
seven for the dwarves and ellen for me
then we see the two trees of eleanor
their branches facing each other we also
see amongst all this the eight-pointed
fan orion star also the sigil of numenor
and when the black sand snakes in the
sand now takes the shape of just one
ring and these countless grains of sand
in the opening credits transition into
the countless stars of the sky seen by
galadriel it's actually pretty parallel
to the way the stranger uses fireflies
as star stand-ins to form his
constellation but here with galadriel
some of the stars stand out likely the
constellation she uses to navigate but
back at the meteor crash site poppy
causes nori to tumble down into it
yes heat is interesting in the show it's
similar to the way the torches in
morgoth's castle that produce no heat
because of all the evil there or the way
that the one rings runes are revealed in
fire yet the ring itself stays quite
cool what is it about evil being
endothermic the stranger grabs nori and
he screams releasing wind and levitating
rebel suggesting that he carries a kind
of sorcery now the popular theory is
that this is gandalf that would
contradict tolkien's original timeline
gandalf and the other wizards were sent
to middle earth during the third age by
the vallar to help fight sauron but the
way this stranger whispers to the
fireflies is actually pretty similar to
the way ian mckellen gandolf whispered
to the moth his stick breaking in the
dirt syncs up perfectly with nori's
dad's ankle snapping the stranger's
experience with the heart puts here
could explain gandalf's affection for
the hobbits later on others are
speculating that this could be a mix of
tolkien's blue wizards who were believed
to have arrived in middle earth during
the second age when the one ring was
forged but since this series is calling
this character the stranger it's clear
that the producers are setting up this
character to be revealed as a well-known
character just with this new origin so
i'm thinking gandalf
ganda
but also maybe sauerman since saruman
would have been the first wizard sent by
the valar if they're sticking with that
origin story at all on to aragion the
elvin smith city where elrond marvels
over this hammer feyenoor's hammer the
two
that brought the sumerians the jewels
that contain the very light of valinor
yes vanor was keller brimboard's
grandfather again this summer else the
three jewels of the wars of the previous
age were bought over kelebrimbor has
apparently learned nothing from history
and now he wants to build an old
testament-style tower of battle in this
case a tower that could host a forge
clearly the forge that will be used to
create the 19 rings i need it completed
by spring why by spring why are you on
such a deadline you jerk i'm guessing he
may have already been approached by
anatar aka sauron's disguise during this
era so they venture to the dwarven
kingdom of kaza doom elrond is surprised
to be denied passage so he invokes the
right of sigintarag which in the
language of kazdul translates to the
right of longbeards because we later
learn this is a test of endurance
between elrond and his old friend prince
during the fourth inside i love how this
city has a thriving kingdom we actually
saw this as ruins of fellowship of the
ring but here back in this era plant
life is sunned by beams of light
directed by mirrors these beams were
actually seen by frodo when the
fellowship took camp in one of the halls
back with nori the stranger repeats the
words mana which means what is and then
ure which means heat so if he is saying
what is heat that again could connect
with this idea of the crash site being
cold maybe this being being unfamiliar
with what heat even is he could come
from some place that has no heat or
warmth at all or someone forged in fire
but has had his memory wiped what that
is meanwhile galadriel swims up on some
wreckage with the castaways fury in the
sea worm and of course the seaworm
strikes again one of these castaways is
halibrand and i just love this single
take of galadriel swimming toward the
camera as hobrond in the background
pushes off and the worm wipes out the
others the first guy gets knocked off
and the camera dives underwater just to
see him get eaten and then the others
get thrown in the water and the tail of
the sea worm swipes them down to the
depths meanwhile after elrond submits to
the challenge during reveals a true
reason he's so pissed off twenty years
may be the blink of an eye tnl but i've
lived an entire life in that time
a life you missed yes so elves live far
longer than the other races do the
producers of the show are condensing
time so that events happen faster so we
wouldn't have to kill off the humans
every season of the show but i like out
here with the relationship between these
two characters they keep the sentiment
of that conflict because elven time
dilation is a serious thing it makes
them detach from the other races one of
the reasons all the other races don't
really trust them durian's wife desa
tells elrond about resonating this is a
dwarven tradition of singing into a
cavern vibrating it with frequency to
clear it and find these mineral deposits
you see a mountain's like a person it's
a long and ever-changing story made of
countless small parts sing to it
properly each of those parts will
reflect your song back to you telling
you it's story where to mine where to
tunnel and and where to leave the
mountain untouched yes untouched is the
interesting part there like the heart
foots the dwarves have this sensitivity
toward nature and in this case when
intervention by men dwarves or elves
pushes nature too far later we see
during his father king during the third
we're actually worried that elrond was
really there to ask about a secret
resource that they keep in a chest
glowing pulp fiction briefcase style i'm
wondering if this could be mithril the
mineral that we see during the fourth
holding in the trailer that of course is
later used to make the chain mail that
frodo wears back on the raft galadriel
spots a necklace with a mysterious
symbol that halbrod hastily tucks away
she thinks it's a sigil of his king and
it is similar to the runes that we see
in the southland in the scene right
after this i'm not wondering if he could
be theo's long-lost southlander father
and he like aragorn could be the king
that they want to return but the tunnels
beneath hoarder and turns out are filled
with orcs some snatch iron deal another
proves to be those bastard mice that
theo's been complaining about under
their home the way they take it down is
pretty impressive bronwyn throws that
orc the jar of powdered fire root that
she warned theo about pulverizing too
quickly in episode one which we see why
when you breathe it in it causes you to
convulse a little bit they defeated
though with bronwyn decapitating it and
slamming that head on the bar getting
its blood all over the camera i love it
back in the storm a lightning bolt
smashes the mast and sends galadriel
sinking to the depths like that stone
and fin rod's parable yet it is the
memory of finrod that ends up saving her
as hal brown uses the thin rod dagger to
cut her free so yes she touches the
darkness and she ends this episode
finding that light again as it blinds
her from seeing the seafarer who has
found them i'm thinking it's gonna be
our man is silder the numenorean who
will one day tell elrond no again i'm
really digging this series we're gonna
try to keep up with it every week either
with breakdowns for me or the very least
some talking tolkien segments on our
talking dragons after show follow me on
tick tock instagram and twitter
boss subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you